on voit des gosses ils ont fait le le
cours préparatoire ils ont fait le cours
élémentaire 2 ils ont été des des
copains à mon fils et puis tout d'un
coup on vient vous dire il est en prison
ça vous rend malade mais on peut pas
baisser les
bras nous sommes à Marseille dans un
grand ensemble comme il y en a beaucoup
d'autres en
France Marie tient une droguerie dans le
centre
commercial rien apparemment qui justifie
atrer l'attention sur
elle marie est une femme dans la cité
parmi d'autres et pourtant pas tout à
fait comme les
autres je le connais pas ton pièce tu es
jamais venu ici hein tu l'as menené ici
oui venu à la maison mais non mais ici
au magasin non passera un jour me
présenter ouais vous avez fixé la
date oui oui oui presque et ben dis donc
com il ça fait que tu le connais il y a
pas tellement longtemps quand même ça
fait ça fait un an non non pas encore
quand même tu vois toi tu crois que ça
fait beaucoup pour nous réch qu Mme
alors ça ça va vous avez escaliers ce
matin non il faut oui maintenant vous
oui
mais ou
ouais non mais ça va la carte d'identité
je sais
vous avez des nouvelles de la belle
fille ah
d'Espagne quien àina
end
vend il est venu se faire soigner en
France il veut un poilon il veut pas
leommod vous la connaissez pas vous
quelle couleur elle le veut elle a pas
d'importance venez voir est-ce qu'elle
le veut comme ça la c ça pas
d'importance c'est un poilon à queue ou
un poilon avec deux à à que alors
regardez regardez Monsieur M là-bas
alors Ernest ça
vanest ça va qu'est-ce que je veux dire
vous avez pas eu trop de vin là-bas dans
la tour parce qu'ici ça soufflait le
soir le soir les portes rien à faire
autrement on peut pas dormir vous avez
fait la
pétition non non on l'a envoyé on n'a
pas de réponse là on va avoir une
entrevue avec la société on va en
reparler de ça hein alors je vous le
dirai si jamais on reçoit d'ailleurs il
va y avoir une mais je viendrais vous
demander parce que il va falloir tirer
ça au clair l'augmentation du loyer
l'augmentation du chauffage on descend
les degrés c'est pas normal on doit on
doit avoir une entrevue et après une
assemblée générale là il faut que vous
veniez à l'Assemblée Gén on est d'accord
même qu'on ne l'
pas le magasin comme ça ça a l'air
distriitant les gens nous dis oh c'est
bien vous vous comprenez vous avez pas
de patron
et mais au fond c'est c'est vrai on oua
8h on ferme à 12 dei puis si un jour on
est en retard il y a personne c'est pas
comme enfin quand je travaillais dans
dans la couture
ou on est tenu à faire tant de pièces à
telle heure et puis il y a non mais
c'est vrai qu'on est un peu plus libre
mais quand même c'est pas moi j'aime
mieux la couture aussi parce que ça ça
apporte plus on me fait que quelque
chose on crée quelque chose et
c'est là on on on achète des produits on
les revend sur le plan personnel il y a
pas tellement d'apport mais quand même
moi je suis bien dans la droguerie parce
que justement j'ai tellement d'autres
choses à faire mais quand j'y suis il y
a une autre ambiance parce que les gens
viennent me voir pour autre chose pour
un tas de
choses des renseignements sur les
locataires sur les logements sur les je
sais pas moi un tas de choses alors mon
mari me dit c'est pas la peine que tu
viennes tu V tu vens rien de plus et en
plus ça mobilise les gens pour rien dans
le
magasin mais quand même c'est pas sur le
plan personnel si on faisait que ça si
on fait que ça ça apporte pas
tellement je sais pas comment une femme
elle peut passer toute sa vie dans un
endroit comme ça sans rien faire d'autre
à
[Musique]
côté
les
enfants sont merveilleux parce que ils
sont toujours en train de
chercher un truc pour pouvoir jouer
comme ils ont envie ils ont pas
tellement de trucs dans la
cité on les voit comme ça grandir dans
la cité privé presque de tout enfin
livré à eux-même et tout c'est bien mais
on aimerait qu'il y ait encore quelque
chose qui quelque chose auquel il puisse
vraiment participer parce que on se rend
compte qu'il y a tellement de de
gaspillage de d'imagination
d'intelligence de capacité manuelle il y
a il y a rien c'est ça c'est ça
alors des fois on a des idées mais pour
les mettre en application si c'est dur
parce que c'est quand même des moyens
qui manquent du personnel et
[Musique]
tout est-ce que vous pensez que vous
pouvez faire un film comme ça
ouiuttre les parents veulent pas qu'
qu'on garde tout ses enfants alors ils
en donnent à quelqu'un ils en gent et
juste un hiver ça fait qu'ils attrapent
Frid il meurent quand je persiste dans
ma conviction que les enfants sont
réceptibles sont intelligents ou alors
sont accrochés par des activités
culturel ou je sais pas des un tas de
choses dont ils n'ont pas l'habitude
d'être sollicité là j'avais fait une
expérience avec les les enfants du coin
sur le plan pratique c'était une erreur
parce que j'ai pas mesuré l'importance
que pouvait prendre la chose parce que
tous les jeudis il en venait davantage
j'étais toute
seule et j'ai bien senti qu'il fallait
quand même quelqu'un d'un peu d'un peu
qualifié d'un qui a habitude de parler
sur plan pédagogique aux enfants quand
même j'avais tellement confiance à eux
que j'ai tenté l'expérience vous avez
des enfants vous les prenez un par un
ils ont rien de différent des autres ils
sont tous prêts à recevoir je sais pas
c'est une pépinière une pépinière
d'intelligence de compétenence de
capacité et et quand je vois qu'on
démolit tout ça qu'on le sacrifie qu'on
le détruit presque on peut pas baisser
les bras c'est pas possible il faut
faire quelque chose vous savez on pourra
faire un pourcentage d'ingénieurs ici et
de jeunes qui ont le le bac et on verra
de suite comme ça tombera et c'est bien
dommage parce qu'au départ ils ont la
même intelligence comme n'importe lequel
aussi bien un Algérien qu'un Français
ils ont la même intelligence la preuve
c'est que quand ça part des maternelles
et que c'est bien suivi et ben il on a
les mêmes résultats et puis à l'adol les
dangers qui les guettent c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable ils peuvent
pas se livrer à ce qu'ils aiment à ce
qu'ils voudraient
faire sur le plan sportif par exemple
comme il y a rien bon ils sont desrés
parfois ils font des groupe on les
appelle des bandes moi je sais pas quand
il tombent dans la
délinquence il y a des causes ils sont
pas responsables
personnellement même la drogue ça
effleure nos quartiers maintenant elle
se ça commence d'ailleurs je sais pas
vous en entendrez parler par d'autres
personnes que
nous alors on voit des gosses ils ont
fait le le cours préparatoire ils ont
fait le cours élémentaire deux ils ont
été des des Copères à mon fils et puis
tout d'un coup on vient vous dire il est
en prison ça vous rend malade mais on
peut pas baisser les bras c'est pas
possible faut faire quelque chose et il
y a quelque chose à faire c'est certain
quand le gosse a compris que pour
lui il y a rien de très beau dans
l'avenir pour lui c'est à peu près tout
bouché il va être je sais pas soudeur ou
mécanicien bon peut-être que ça lui
plairait mais dans d'autres condition
encore moi je suis pas d'accord quand on
dit c'est c'est des cités où il y a des
voyou mais on les fabrique les voyou
vous savez on les fabrique hein on leur
donne tous les éléments pour qu'il le
deviennent il faut pouvoir leur donner
autre chose il faut pouvoir les
intéresser il faut pouvoir leur faire
les leur faire aimer quelque chose on a
vu le film on a vu toutes les danses
algériennes toutes les danse des des
antillers on a tout vu ouais ou ouais
ouais ou ouais ouais et et c'était
drôlement bien alors si ça peut faire
avancer un peu le racisme tu vois la
lutte contre le racisme je trouve qu'on
doit faire des trucs comme ça trouve pas
même que c'est une fête Sam 29 avril à
15h sur un terrain du club des trois
cités ça font ver chez nous maintenant
on arrive à un âge où moi
personnellement j'exige autre chose mais
je vois qu'il y a
rien au-delà de la camaridorie personne
donne autre chose c'estàd tout le monde
se limite à un sourire tout va bien
bonjour ah c'est on a passé une on va
faire une journée aujourd'hui ben on va
bien s'amuser puis voilà quand on rentre
bon ça va ben si on a des ennuis on les
retrouve personne ne cède voilà ce que
ce que je crois comprendre c'est que
quand vous êtes plus jeune c'est qu'elle
vous pèse pas trop la Vie dans la Cité
non quand vous êtes plus jeune c'est
après à l'adolescence que vous commencez
à perdre un peu pied c'est dire parce
qu'on voit d'autres problèm voilà voilà
quand on est jeune on voit pas tout tout
ce qu'on voit ça nous suffit qui c'est
beau moi je sais qu'avant que je viens
habiter dans dans une cité pour moi ces
bâtiments c'était les maisons neuve dans
mon esprit d'enfant ça fait quelque
chose de beau une maison neuve mais
quand je suis venu habiter bon on voit
vraiment la concentration humaine puis
on voit qu'il y a rien d'autre béton
puis il y a rien ouais je suis pas
tellement d'accord avec Patricia c'est
parce que elle refuse de regarder ce qui
se passe autour d' regarder tu refuses
de regarder tu verras rien il faut
regarder vivre moi enfin j'ai toujours
envie de la regarder cette cité moi pour
moi le vit je crois que chez beaucoup de
gens il y a des choses qui demandent
quelquefois un petit un petit contact un
petit déclic et on est étonné de ce
qu'on reçoit en
[Musique]
échange ma mère habite pas très loin
je vais laavir au moins une fois par
semaine si c'est pas plus parce qu'elle
est toujours inquiète elle se demande
toujours si on est malade si on
est l je vais la voir
très
contente geldise ne
diyor ne
diyor şey gelsin ben yatıracak Yerim de
Var gezcek Yerim de
var
[Musique]
mes parents quand ils sont arrivés
d'Arménie il se sont pas du tout intégré
ils ont eu beaucoup de mal à perdre
leurs murs leurs habitudes et je me
rappelle de toutes les maisons de
famille arménienne et il y avait un
tapis barriolet avec des des dessins
géométriques mais très orientaux et
là-dessus ben on faisait asseoir les
invités le soir quand on allait dans
lesveillers parce que ils se sont
regroupés dans des villages où il y
avait des usines pour avoir des contrat
pour avoir des contrats qui leur
permettaient d'être en règle pour rester
en France pour avoir une carte
d'identité de travailleurs tout ça et il
y avait surtout des fonderies dans
l'Ardèche ben je me souviens on allait à
la veillée euh du village dans le bourg
et tout le temps à la veillée on parlait
que des massacres on est imprégné de ça
les Arméniens sont imprégné de ça et par
exemple ma mère elle a du mal elle a du
mal à se trouver heureuse quelquefois
parce que quand elle se elle se souvient
de tout ça elle est ça monte toujours on
lui a enfin on a tué de ses frères on a
tué on avait tué le père de mon père
enfin ils ont que ils avaient que des
souvenirs comme ça et puis quand même
ils étaient tellement imprégnés des murs
la femme tout ça mon père l'a laissé pas
pas sortir c'est lui qui faisait les
commissions et ce qui fait que c'est mon
père qui avait fait des progrès il avait
appris à copier les adresses avec les
lettres qu'il recevait il était très
intelligent il avait pas de
d'instruction mais il était très
intelligent je retrouve
enfin je retrouve les mêmes situations
avec les petits algériens dans le
quartier quand ils arrivent avec leur
maman et ils parlent enfin le leur
langue et puis le petit traduit oh je me
mets à leur place c'est c'est formidable
parce que je fais attention je suis
passée par là vous savez mon père savait
pas très bien parler français quand on
allait faire des démarches je sais pas
dans les commissariats dans les mairies
il s'enlevait toujours la casquette il
avait toujours la le paquet de cigarette
à la main il était très humble mais en
même matin moi ça me ça me hérissait
parce que je me disais il a pas le droit
on n pas le droit de le considérer comme
ça je me rappelle un jour pour une carte
d'identité qu'on lui a dit euh de profil
et moi j'étais assise un peu plus loin
sur un ban dans le dans la pièce là du
commissariat j'étais malheureuse comme
tout de profils vous rendez compte ils
sont en France et puis ils savent même
pas ce que ça veut dire de profil alors
je me suis levée je je lui ai expliqué à
mon père c'est des ce sont des choses
qui qui marquent et qui murissent tout
petit quoi la coutume voulait qu'on se
marie avec des gens sérieux puis que
d'autres connaissaient à partir de 15
ans on a eu des demandes en
mariage très rapproché quoi on venait
voir un peu comme ils font pour les
Algériens là on venait voir la jeune
fille si elle était signalée sérieuse
travailleuse il venait avec les avec les
parents puis la belle-mère regardait oh
puis après on en a eu marre avec mes
sœurs on a dit on reste plus fallait
leur offrir le café pendant qu'il nous
détaillait pour voir si on boîit pas ou
alors on a dit on en a assez maintenant
on reste plus mon père mais c'est pour
votre bien mais enfin vous savez que si
je vous si je vous conseille ce garçon
et cette famille c'est que vous serez
bien ils ont de l'argent ils ont un
métier et ça a pas marché parce que
enfin on avait un peu lu la Martine et
puis grziel là et puis on se demandait
on savait qu'il y avait autre chose quoi
l'amour c'était pas ça on s'en est bien
vite rendu compte de se marier comme on
a voulu
toute c'est pour ça alors à force de
lutter contre des choses comme ça et
puis on est poussé à des prises de
conscience
et jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve une une
véritable conviction pour pas abandonner
la lutte
quoi pas
oh Louis disliui quelque chose il arrive
ça une à l'endroit une à l'envers là
mais c'est Louis qui a tiré ça c'est
loui qui Fa gager du papier il VI pas
venir il m'a invité avec Jan aussi
mais revi et tout qui pouvit le faire
mais là c'est fini
he mais il y en a pas ass non non non on
va fa pour les
on à moins qu'on le fasse dans un
boî
on s met après au 4au Paris toi et moi
qui oui oui on va all
[Musique]
chercher bonjour Mo comment ça va
bonjour ça va très bien dites-moi euh
mercredi il va y avoir une réunion à la
maison de quartier alors on invite
toutes les femmes enfin celles qui
peuvent venir alors est-ce que vous
allez pouvoir venir si je peux vraimême
avec le travail que j'ai vous savez avec
Sim oh vous sortez jamais quand
même fait mercredi là il a une réunion
de femmes si vous voulez venir moi j'y
vaisz qui vient ben c'està-dire ça
dépend si vous voulez amener je vaux le
faire moi je l'ai fait de haut en bas
voilà si elles veulent venir parce que
voyez il y a la femme dans la cité alors
il y a des discussions par exemple
mercredi il y aura la discussion bonjour
Daniel aura la discussion sur le budget
oui je sais pas ça vous intéresse si
vous voulez venir ça faut passer un
moment dans cette maison de quartier
toutes les organisations sont
représentées on essaie de d'y faire
démarrer beaucoup
d'activités une commission
de la presse s'est mise sur pied avec
les la représentation de 10 associations
le docteur Antonini demande la
possibilité d'insérer dans cette dans ce
numéro un article sur le problème de la
drogue le problème des jeunes un comité
provisoire des jeunes s'est constitué et
ce comité travaille au lancement de la
maison de jeune l'activité sur le
racisme qui s'est déroulé du 23 au 26
mars a vu la participation de 1500
personnes ça a été quand même très
positif le principe de la fête au
village a été admis parout cette fête se
déroulera chez nous du 18 au 25 juin et
nous avons tous constaté que dans nos
cité les gens se connaissent peu ou se
connaissent mal c'est pour ça que la
fête devrait permettre aux gens de
sortir de chez eux d'être dans la rue de
se rencontrer dans un climat de détente
les problèmes que nous avons soulevés le
7 le bus le terrain d'évolution les
parkings les travaux du stade qui sont
stoppés un immeuble de U étages qui
restent prévu sur le complexe sportif
tous ces problèmes soulevés depuis 1 an
n'ont pas reçu de solution et devant
donc cet état de fait la concertation
est momentanément arrêtée cette maison
de quartier qui a été construite
récemment on en sentit un besoin depuis
très très longtemps ça a des limites
mais c'est un endroit
où on peut se réunir pour découvrir
certains problèmes ensemble
elle a l'air vide comme ça même parfois
lorsque je la regarde de ma fenêtre de
ma maison je regarde la cité la pelouse
les
bâtiments c'est vrai qu'elle a l'air
d'une maquette bien construite avec des
petites allées et puis on a l'air de
penser qu'il va y avoir des gens qui
vont passer là là là puis rentrer dans
les petites boîtes qui sont les maisons
mais en fait à tous les étages il y a
des problèmes il y a une vie intense il
y a des familles il y a des enfants et
nous on les connait parce que ça fait 12
ans qu'on est ici
elle est pas morte la cité c'est pas
vrai elle est pas morte seulement il
faut y vivre pour savoir comment elle
vit c'est vrai qu'il y a peu de moyens
de
communication ce qui fait que les gens
ils ont pas tellement envie de sortir de
chez eux c'est
vrai particulier pour les jeunes et pour
les femmes les femmes surtout parce
qu'elles sont obligées de
rester à la maison quoi enfin il y en a
qui travail et c'est encore plus pénible
parce que lorsqu'elles arrivent elles
ont pas le temps de passer dans la cité
de vivre dans la cité elles quittent un
bus ou un moyen de transport puis elles
s'engouffrre dans leur maison et il y a
encore du travail qui les atteint
comment voulez-vous que ces femmes-là
elles aient envie de sortir de parler
puisque leur temps est limité leurs
soucis sont sans nombre par contre c'est
pas vrai que les gens sont indifférents
c'est pas vrai qu'ils sont amorphes
parce que quand il y a un problème
brûlant par exemple une école qui manque
ils sont combatif ils sont prêts à faire
quelque chose pour qu'on parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils ont droit quand c'est
brûlant ils réagissent par exemple pour
les expulsions il y a eu des expulsions
mais alors c'était des gens qui étaient
honnêtes enfin des gens qui étaient
estimé par les par par l'entourage quand
même du jour au lendemain on apprend
qu'on les expulse bon ben il y a eu des
problème tout ça de loyer de guuissier
mais les femmes surtout ont réagit votre
dame elle va bien oui ça va ça va vous
avez plus de bébé non fini est ça y est
ça suffit
maintenant bien bon au revoir bon journ
au revoir monsieur cherchou bonjour à la
maisonin
merci écoute il faut il faut qu' il faut
tu m'as chercherement ici comm ça je
descend par là là o c'est vous êtes
maintenant à Saint- Paul euh oui mais
comment on fait il y en a pas
d'appartement il faut faire la demande à
la Mairie faut faire la demande tu a
fait la demande là là ça fait G a fait
la demande en 69 70 71 oui vous avez vu
l'assistante
sociale l'assistante soci et oui il faut
aller voir l'assistante soci la location
la location où là vous savez au centre
social vous lui expliquez pourquoi vous
voulez venir par ici
c'està-dire
pas les chambres c'est petit là-bas et
vous touchez pas la location l à partir
le mois de mois de août pourquoi et
parce que là il a trois chambres il faut
il faut C alors si vous avez C chambres
vous trouchez la location ce qu'il
aurait fallu c'est que les gens fassent
des pétitions par couloir elle a
toujours fait ça toujours pareil mais
non non monsieur anosiat quand même il
le craigne un peu quand même c'est comme
ça me pas Malu il ou
mais oui mais parce qu'on se laisse
faire ils y sont derrière l'Amicale les
G personne qui marche main dans la main
oui là Sam me dit on va y avoir une
réunion pour les pour l'augmentation des
loyers on va me parler de ça de de de de
du truc de qu'on a pas Repin qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça alors vous savez si
vous le faites chacun le refait son
tranquille il dépin plus en rang
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire le mur
écoutez moi j'étais un des promiers et
vous le savez oui oui je le sais sais a
pas payé fout deors et tout le monde ce
qui fait de bruit non mais c'est pas ils
sont ven av là je dire savez ce qui
s'est passé
pay
exp vous savez que on vous a fait passer
un papier sur lequel il y avait écrit
que nous avions obtenu un délai de 3
mois pour les gens qui encaissaient
après le 5 d'aller avertir le régisseur
que il pouvait pas payer le 5 je crois
que justement j'ai moi-même j'ai vu le
le gardien et question que je pay le 7
ou le 8 il n'est pas d'accord avec moi
pas mal moi aussi je suis payé le 7 et
je pourrais payer le 8 comment je
voulez-vous que je paye le loyer le
prier mois ou le 3 du mois il faut qu'il
paye le 5 il est payé le 7 et ben nous
en parlerons vend pour pour rassurer les
gens voyez qui n'ont pas signé qui ont
gardé leurs feuilles à la maison ou qui
l'ont laissé ici du moment que vous avez
vos quittances de loyer c'est pas
possible qu'on vous donne congé et de
toute façon s'il arrivait cela à qui que
ce soit
je pense qu'il faut avertir l'amical des
locataires les responsables que vous
connaissez hein mon activité dans le
quartier je fais très attention pour que
ma famille en souffre le moins possible
parce que au
fond peut-être ça m'a c'est pas
tellement une recherche de la de la
satisfaction personnelle je sais pas
parce que des fois j'essaie d'analyser
pour voir si c'est égoïste quoi de de
faire ce que je fais parce que est-ce
que c'est pour moi personnellement mais
mais je pense que non parce que euh par
exemple je suis très bien avec mon mari
et mon et mon petit garçon je suis très
très bien je voudrais rester longemps
avec eux parce qu'avec eux il y a
dialogue il y a il y a échange il y a on
s'ennuie jamais on s'ennuie jamais tous
les trois même quand je m'envis à des
réunions mon fils il reste avec mon mari
il s'ennuie
pas
mais je sais pas je pense enfin je pense
pas quand même peut-être que mon fils
euh
quelquefois me dit quand même tu devrais
moins moins sortir moins partir le le
soir mais je suis sûre que si j'étais
autrement des fois je lui dis tu
voudrais que je suis comme que je sois
comme une madame telle ou ah il me dit
non alors alors je lui dis tu vois bien
que finalement tu es assez content de de
ce que je fais il me dit oui mais tu
fais trop alors il y en a pourquoi les
les autres en FR pas un petit peu et toi
moins mais je dis ça c'est plus dur à
obtenir
[Musique]